oh
no
it doesn't save the loot that i had
oh
oh man
damn it it just saves the map does it i
don't know hold on
no it does
it does it does okay i'm good i'm good
i'm back i'm back baby so i'm healed up
i've got
bullets
and
the
oh
oh god oh god oh do i have an escape
here okay i do
okay
okay i'm ready i'm ready you ready
i'm ready
you ready i guess i'm going into it i
guess we're just doing this huh ain't we
isn't we
is we not his we you got 881 health
that's pretty good i'm gonna bait it
i've got all this meat i better start
using it i just gotta make sure that i
try to get the traps back because
sometimes they don't break which i
forgot oh
my god
man i'm gonna tag this guy
i'm gonna tag him with a gps sensor
you're gonna get tagged and then bagged
keeping my eye on you
i'm not letting him get away i am the
hunter here where you at big man where
are you foot fetish bastard well he's
probably not here i say with confidence
oh the glass
ow
what the hell's that about
can i not break that off is that always
going to be like that oh [ __ ]
well that's annoying maybe i shouldn't
be here
oh god please don't tell me he's right
around the corner
oh my god he's right around the corner
i'm gonna tag you
take one of these okay
all right um okay well that's not how
that i expected that to go uh
we're gonna play a game
it's called uh don't come in here i
almost stepped on that come on come on
come on what have you got what do you
get what do you got where are you at i
wanted to put into you oh yeah yeah you
better get over here you better get over
here some tasty and delicious
oh he's he's playing me i know this he's
waiting he's intentionally being patient
and only coming out when i come out i
feel like the leaning trees are all
traps and they're all leaning
oh i see oh i see it okay i see the trap
okay so you physically see the trap
that's there
i'm gonna shoot it
holy crap close it
oh my god
come at me come at me i need this gps
sensor
damn it
come on come on come on
got him
oh god i don't have the fuel cancer done
oh the trap
the trap why is the trap not working oh
no
why did the trap not work does trap not
work
did i not lay down i didn't lay down a
trap did i oh my god i'm out of here oh
god he's right there he's right there
he's right there he's running away he's
a little baby he's a little baby did i
pick up the trap that i got down
i have three traps why don't i have
enough traps there's not enough traps
there's my trap
oh
my god stop
i pick that up oh god okay but i see him
now okay i see him i know where he is i
don't know how long the sensor looks i
did the thing
i did the thing oh my god i need to heal
oh my god
i'm not doing great i'm not doing great
i'm really embarrassing myself out here
rick
head of the society of whatever is a
bigfoot
not doing too great
did i go in here
yes yes i'm doing great i'm doing the
best
i'm the best
oh i'm the best
oh
that's okay i know where he is
okay full up on that don't need that
pistol is okay yeah i'm truly full on
ammo which is not
where i thought i'd be but i need to
take advantage of the situation or else
i'm just gonna lose it all
oh
oh
where does this lead
that looks secluded
oh yeah that's nice
that's right in the middle of
nothingness
i'm looking for traps okay he's circling
back island rangers house okay
that's good he's coming back towards me
not a good sign oh god he's gone he's
off my radar now
oh boy
where
oh my god
please tell me i should be able to see
him coming
if he's over there
i should be able to see him coming from
a mile off which means that i can defend
this spot because i can put cameras
at least one camera north side he can't
sneak up on me and i haven't escaped
back and forth right so i'm gonna put a
camera right
there
let's go like that
let's bait him
bait it up
now who's setting the traps [ __ ]
now who's doing it oh [ __ ] there he is
wow
oh who's waddling in the water
oh who's waddling
oh wow
oh goodness gracious drink i miss that
one
i don't know if it's hit scan or actual
bullet
i think it might be bullet lexi and give
the definition of hit scan versus uh
bullet physics in games and what the
difference is all right where are you at
big guy oh there you are
i can't tell where i'm firing it maybe
just like really far away
i don't know what the bullet physics are
like here
oh it's hit skin
is it
all right you're all the way over there
but that's still not very far away
it's close enough to matter that's for
sure this seems like the perfect place
to string him up the game has changed
bigfoot
i'm coming for you foot man
[Applause]
oh
there you are
i'm gonna let him get closer
hope never mind easy pickings ah
come on how do i hit this guy
he's got a stick
he's got a stick
there we go
748 still not a lot of damage dealt
i wish he was closer but
i should let him get closer because if
he's all the way over here i'm just
gonna get keep taking pot shots at him
and i'm never gonna actually finish him
off i'll i'll know when he's coming
because he's gonna hit those traps and
i'm gonna be able to see him from the
the cameras so unless he goes around the
back which i don't know if he will i
might be able to see him coming
i should be pretty good here okay so
that leads back into the mainland
again single point of entry wish i'd
save some cameras before i came over
here but i think this might be it
this is a good one lots of totems too
which is um
more concerning than uh comforting
can i get a picture of bigfoot does that
do anything for me
oh hey bud oh he's coming i'm gonna let
him get all the way over here
i'm gonna watch him on the camera
actually hey bud i see you can i fly the
drone
no signal
does it need to charge
whoa
you got a lot closer than i thought
where are you
where are you
where are you
hold on
whoa
go away
where is he
did he get caught on one of my traps
can't tell
oh my god he did he's coming
okay okay okay
all right
come at me
nice
nice
now he's got to come over that bridge
and i've got a perfect vantage point to
keep pepper in him
where are you at where you at
come on
come on
where'd you go where'd you go
it's a hit where to go he's coming
yep
i don't know how easy it is to get here
come on where are you at
come here
oh
goodbye
41.
hey don't don't break the zipline
that's uh mean
oh yeah i've got him on the ropes
i found it i found the right way come on
bud
come on you want some of this
you want
me here right for you
delicious meat
it cannot be beat
i might have left a trap up there too
and i don't think he's going to come
back because i did a lot of damage to
him oh nope never mind right right there
all right you want to play
i'll play with you
where'd you go
oh
wait a minute did he just jump off the
mountain
are you coming over here what are you
doing what are you doing
what's the plan what's the plan what's
the plan what's the plan pal where'd he
go is that him
is that him yeah that's him is that him
yeah
come at me where'd you go oh oh it's
coming
uh-huh
oh god oh god oh god oh my god he's mad
he's mad he's mad he's mad
he's very mad
but not man enough
where you going
that's what i thought down to 209 almost
dead
oh still scary all right mama finish you
off stop healing i don't care what
you're eating
i better get your ass over here i got a
whole bullet buffet for you
these dunzo
that one is
one trap left all right you hungry you
hungry a bigfoot hunky bigfoot won a
bite to eat
bigfoot won a bullet buffet
that would bigfoot want
bigfoot huh all right i'm gonna take the
fight to bigfoot
let's do this
come on bigfoot where you at
where you at where you at you went this
way
well what what
did the ground not just start shaking
with the thunderous thunder of a bigfoot
stampede
did that not just happen just beautiful
yellowstone very gorgeous it's still not
day yet actually i thought it was day i
thought day was coming
it is not day
oh hi
hello
how you doing i'm not here for you
oh my god what
well that's weird
what is that
oh
hey easy
whoa
what is with this
it's like a little structure
bigfoot you getting crafty what is
happening what is going on
i don't like it what is going on
you was it you
that was so much rustling was that all
you okay it's day now
ah
a little campsite ain't that lovely
ain't that lovely ain't that lovely
ain't that
well
another one of those traps going up
great
okay i don't need another r 700
man once i get good at this man me and
the boys me and the boys go oh my god
holy crap
okay
i feel like that's a bit more than just
the guys are going off
hunting tower two
that's good 12 gauge good
12 gauge good empty good
blood good camera whoa oh my god whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i will fight
you what
you were too fast
well that was startling
[Music]
our evidence found i still have even
found a body i've almost killed bigfoot
and i've found nothing
oh
what the hell
that was
so
loud
kind of birds do that i don't know where
he is
but he can't have gone too far and one
night he only wondered about this area
i'm actually gonna cut through the woods
here i know it's not a smart idea to cut
ho ho ho ho ho
i know it's not smart to cut through the
woods but i'm gonna cut through the
woods i know it's starting to be night
and i know this is really dumb but i'm
doing it anyway because i'm confident in
my abilities
as a hunter
as the lead investigator of the bigfoot
research alliance i don't like that i'm
going towards the bigfoot
i knew that it was gonna happen
before i even stepped on it because the
creaking was getting louder and louder i
knew that was gonna happen
i don't even know where i'm going
it's like super dense forest
uh go away plane you don't want to see
this i am so exposed
i am so exposed i can only hope that
this car was pointed towards something
that's a bloody handprint and then maybe
he was trying to go somewhere where it
could seek shelter and i'll go that way
because i'm assuming that it was going
somewhere oh god
oh i'm boned i'm boned i'm boned what do
we got
shelter three shelter two shelter two
has a gate
uh go shelter three shelter three
shelter three is a shelter for me
oh
that's shelter three
this is shelter three
oh my god the other one oh this oh
no no no no get out of here oh what
how did you do that
how'd you do that
huh how'd you do that i want to make my
way to shelter three it's got to be
something more because it had a gate on
it therefore it must be something where
a car could park i should have realized
that please be a building please a year
ass
yes
a building
shelter three is the shelter for me is
that a well
holy crap give me some what's locked up
okay i don't know what i'm wasting time
for i gotta get inside i gotta set a
trap i gotta find whatever explosive is
in here and i gotta put it up now
hello
goodbye
okay crap
let's draw him in
because i feel confident and handsome
okay green i don't think i ever got
green oh did i ever get green i might
have gotten green and i just don't
realize it decent supplies full of shock
and ammo oh it's right there 7155 okay
i don't know what's in here oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh baby
okay well he's got to come in here for
this to work he has to be here
putting that right there
because i'm about to blast his ass into
grass
i don't want to buy the door because
it's going to just blow
oh my god
get blasted oh my god oh my god i was
right next to it oh my god that was
terrible why did i do that
please don't please don't kill me please
i thought oh
no
no
h-h-h-h-h-hhh
i thought that if i i thought i'd pull
out the detonator not blow it
immediately
come on come on come on come on
all right that couldn't have gone worse
that could not have gone worse i could
not have planned that to go worse i
thought it pulled out the detonator and
then i had to press it again i thought i
remembered that from last time but
apparently that was not the case
all right come on come on come on you
wanna dance you wanna dance do i have
any i have no traps left
zero traps all broken he's so weird
because he's never tripped any of my
cameras except in the beginning of this
i don't see him
where did he go
usually he's so active but maybe because
he's low on health he's being more
cautious is that something he can do
is that even a thing oh come on
where you at
where you at this is nerve-wracking just
sitting here in the middle of the woods
waiting
but i don't know where to go because i
can't really go after him because i
don't have a gps on him and i screwed up
the dynamite placement
because i'm an idiot
i blew it up right under my feet i
should be dead by now i should be 10
pieces of markiplier strewn across the
lake bed i should just be atomized meat
but somehow rick is tough enough to
survive my body certainly wouldn't have
been able to handle that but maps rick
might
rick just might the whole night is gone
come on fine i'm just gonna go is it
gonna go when look at this
we got some tents wolf coyote wolf oh no
wolf whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
hey hey whoa
holy crap
ow
i don't need the meat
uh
oh god every time
oh [ __ ] oh that drew in oh that drew him
okay i see how it is
i see how it is you want to mess with me
huh laptop
you coming
how many
freaking
how many freaking feet picks can i get
well another night and i didn't finish
it i thought i might but i did not ooh
wait a minute that's a that's a fire
watch tower
i love that game this is so
fitting
this looks
a lot like the fire watch tower from
firewatch
but maybe that's because of course it
does what was his name what was the sign
guys name what was sign guy's name i
don't even remember who's his name
sign man sign stanley no stanley no
stanley no
why do i think stanley where's stan no
not stanley stanley
stanley well
this is about as good a place as any to
see
the lay of the land
and it's a good lay
let me let me run down here it's such a
clear opening that is
that is the ideal there's so many good
bigfoot kill zones in this
and there's so many bad ones and for
some reason i've chosen all the bad ones
first and i don't know why
but i'm gonna make my way to a few more
landmarks and then i'm gonna come back
to the firewatch tower all right
please give me a trap or an explosive
please please
damn
all right bolts it is
oh trap oh yes love that i'm golden i'm
going back to the uh firewatch tower
oh yeah he's at 332 with just a little
bit more to heal i really want to take
him out this night
i really do which means i probably got
to put a gps sensor and then i gotta
shoot him enough so he starts running
away and then take the fight to him
this is what i gotta do there's no other
way i'm going to save the trap for
getting inside because i want to take as
many shots as possible while he's trying
to bash down my door
that gives me the most opportunity and
then i do want to hit him with a gps
sensor i also want to try the drone
again because for some reason that
wasn't working
there we go i feel like if i was trying
to min max this game which i'm not but
if i was if i played a few more times i
will if i was it would be about making a
base of operations with like
two rings of three cameras like kind of
like three in a triangle and three in an
opposite triangle and then making like
supply runs and then coming back to a
base
this is why i wish it was kind of
crafting you could make bigfoot even
more dangerous if you had crafting like
better defenses to like oh
shoot oh my god he's here
when did he get here
that was him right
oh my god oh my god
holy crap
okay um holy crap uh
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay
damn it
oh boy here we go
oh boy here we go
i'm out i'm out babe ow
freaking hell
holy [ __ ]
damn it didn't get nearly enough
oh my god
all right all right buddy where you at i
didn't even get a gps sensor on them i'm
gonna get him i'm gonna lead him back up
here
i'm gonna try to get a sensor on him
come back here get back here
where are you at
damn it i keep screwing up my chances
then i'm never gonna be able to kill him
whoa where's that oh really you're over
there huh
you coming to me
hmm
oh my god
oh my god stop that
okay he's near the camper but why are
you oh
hey
what are you doing you
nerd what are you doing
he like gives up he only tries once a
night
he really does nothing i had him on the
ropes and he keeps getting away from me
he's gonna win
whoa oh my god
that's terrifying
that's properly terrifying
i hate it i don't like the idea of going
to yellowstone i know that it won't blow
up and kill me but i also know that if i
go it's gonna be the moment that it
blows up surprises everybody everyone
will be like oh we didn't think this
could happen and then i i'll be like
it's me guys i showed up to yellowstone
and it blew up it's my fault i know and
we're all dead so none of this matters
so screw you i never wanted to come here
in the first place and that's
that's what will happen where even am i
going
oh my god it's the loudest tiny thing
ever
oh it's a pig
get out of here
it's not like i need any more ammo i'm
just trying to find traps
that's not a big oh
come back here wait
come on
come here you
oh come here you
you get back here damn it i missed all
of my sensors i missed everything
oh i missed this ammo from the beginning
ah
all i want to do
is get him in a corner
tag him and finish him off
i know i can do it i haven't even found
the missing people and i've gone all
over this island it's taken me forever
to get around here and i only just now
got back now this bastard won't even
show his face what if i drop a bunch of
meat on the ground huh what if i just
drop meat can i even drop meat i don't
think i can how am i not seeing you
you're here somewhere
oh got him so i can't get too close
because then the foliage gets too deep
i see you're crossing that bridge
understood
no you're not you're going north you're
just creeping along that way okay
that's good
in pursuit he's just over this hill
oh it's the freaking totem
there he is
come here
yeah you gonna run are you gonna come to
me
where'd he go what
he went into those bushes and just
disappeared
what he went into those bushes and just
disappeared he literally went into the
bushes i shot him as he was going into
the bushes and then he never came out of
the bushes
what
what are these bushes made out of is it
a teleporting bush
this bush porter i don't know what
happened i i should be able to see him
because i'm right
i'm right over there
he can't have gone far
my drone would be able to see him
and yet he's nowhere and now it's gonna
be night and he's gonna come after me
anyway okay
very very strange and now i'm caught out
in the middle of nothingness
great
this is great
he has 283 health he's been in the 280s
forever
i see nothing it's too dark
oh god oh god oh hey
all right
here we go gps sensor
oh i was gonna throw that first and then
you whoa oh my god oh my god where are
you where are you don't run away
ah i got him
you're mine you're mine you're mine
you're mine
where you going where you think you're
going
where do you even think you're going
come back here
stop running away no no no no no
not this time
not this time i've got my eyes on you
crossing the river that's gonna slow you
down
i know i got my eyes on you where'd you
go
come here
come back here
stop running away it's like he doesn't
want to die
man my my theme my targeting thing is
going to run out soon i know
there he is
there he is
he left over up that like it was nothing
god oh god
ow okay i'm fine there he is
you gonna run away
yep
he's running
there you go where are you going
i'm here you where you can't go much oh
you
you
you dick you going to your cave this is
where your cave is this might be where
his cave is
oh my god if this is his cave
oh this might be a dead end for you
buddy this might be a dead end for you
for you oh god where'd it go he just
turned off
if he's not going into the water then
he's gonna have more room to wiggle
i think he went up here but i'm not sure
oh where is he
where is he
no
how did i lose him
oh
how did i lose him 243
oh
oh god
he's right there he's right there he's
right there what are you injured well
can you not run very far oh i don't
think he can run very far
yeah you're afraid now
come on come on you won't go
i need something more than the
then the machine gun can do
[Music]
not that not that
where'd you go where'd you go
yeah i know i know i know
i'm 43.
where you at where are you at
damn
oh 143 and he's gonna heal back up again
god he's like he just doesn't want to
die it's like so dark with the rain i
can't see any of my flashlights off
that would explain it 188 oh my god i
just can't get him just let me get him
i'm so out of everything i've looted the
whole damn island
what bear
bear
i didn't know there was a bear here
oh hello i think if you leave carcasses
of animals uh bigfoot also comes
stomping by
just not sure about that
okay now at least i can get the drone
out
ah [ __ ] drones out of batteries god and
now it's day again oh this
bastard
there we go
i'm gonna butcher this animal and i'm
hoping that it leads you here
to me
wait
i remember something okay
i can't take that because i got two but
that's okay i remember something there's
an explosive
in the house
down south
and
if i go there
i can get it there is an explosive
there's one
there is i'm on the way
this is what's going to end this fight
once and for all finally
me
and bigfoot
one
versus the other
destiny is calling me
open up my eagle eyes
oh hello
oh hello bigfoot what are you doing over
here
found you
oh no
someone's shooting you
and you're on a very long flat plane
oh no
that's okay
i need something before i can finish you
off but i did get some good damage in
i did i did he was probably making traps
over here for me
for this final night
this is the final night now was it here
i don't remember where specifically it
was so long
right here
where i left it many a moon ago
waiting
for the perfect shot
for the perfect shot
for the perfect shot
all right bigfoot
i'm here
i'm ready
i'm ready to do this
i'm ready to end this right now
i want to
i've been waiting for it i've been
yearning for it you know what that's not
even gonna be the first thing i do
because i want you to pass through that
no
i'm gonna save it for after i'm gonna
come back around when you
and i'm gonna slam
that
perfectly
you come here
you show me what you're made of
oh [ __ ] he's showing me what i'm what
he's made of
show me what you're made of
come here where are you
can't seem to hit you all right
you're in i'm out why i said i was out
no you don't no you don't no you don't
run away from this
you don't run away from this
big fly
i
am
livid
i'm so mad
i'm so mad god why didn't i jump out the
window
why did he not let me jump
out the window and then i couldn't shoot
him from my window because i i saw his
leg
i shot his leg
oh my god i swear if this makes me go
another goddamn night
i swear to god this is
[ __ ] ridiculous
i have to do i'm doing 30 damage a night
[Music]
i'm gonna burn you again you [ __ ]
there he goes
there he goes design
design i'm burning we're burning we're
going hell together you [ __ ]
yes
[Music]
it was literally a fiery finish
you
you
it's fine but i got you
i got you
i got you
you can't be me
not anymore so that is bigfoot the ai
has made him more uh self-defensive he's
not just a rampaging machine at night
but that makes him a bit more
frustrating to hunt when you're alone
but not impossible i beat you
i'll beat you mr foot
i am the most shirt in the woods now so
next time
you might be hunting me out there
oh wait i already made a documentary
about that thank you everybody so much
for watching check out more bigfoot in
the description below and more scary
games on my channel everywhere
and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you